this is Noah in 1976 Noah was born in
the United States of America to a man
named John and a woman named Sarah John
and Sarah were married and had one other
boy before Noah named Alex neither John
nor Sarah was exceptionally intelligent
or talented but they worked reasonably
hard in their careers to make up for it
and create a life for themselves at the
time of Noah's birth they made enough
money to provide a sense of security for
themselves and for their two sons but
not enough to feel any extra comfort
they were not poor but pennies were
often pinched and corners were often cut
in order to sustain for all intents and
purposes they were average dead center
middle America
as time would pass Noah and his brother
would start to ingest and understand
more of the world around them they began
to grasp the conditions of their lives
and form their personalities and
perspectives Noah and Alex were quite
different Alex was a very positive
individual who always tried to see
things through an optimistic lens he
understood his parents situation and
recognized that they were doing their
best with what they could and he loved
them for that he appreciated what he had
and loved enjoying the simple things in
life he liked camping drawing and
playing the guitar Noah however it was
far more pessimistic about his
conditions and desirous of something
bigger and better he saw the world as a
game of numbers in levels one with
winners and losers one where money and
status determined the winners and one
that he felt like he and his family were
losing and this upset Noah Noah first
made this determination for himself back
when he was 10 years old and all of his
friends got a new popular toy everyone
had this toy and it seems so cool so
Noah asked his parents for one when they
told him they would not be able to get
it for him Noah didn't understand why
his parents told him that they didn't
have the extra money to spend on an
expensive new toy at the time and that
he should just enjoy the toys he had but
Noah's still didn't understand why he
wondered what his parents didn't do
right to be like his friend's parents he
wanted to be like his friends and have
his friends families and have that toy
he wondered what it must be like to be
that happy when Noah was 12 his father
got a decent-sized promotion at the
company he worked for going from a floor
position to a managerial role Noah and
his family's life would change
significantly almost overnight
Noah would now have access to some of
the extra comfort and niceties that many
of his friends had
the family he wished for he now had most
of the toys he wanted he could now get
Noah continued to grow older into high
school when he turned 16 he got his
license no observed many of his friends
get new cars from their parents as a
gift when they got their licenses so
Noah asked his parents if they would get
him one his dad said that even though
things were going pretty well
it wasn't wise to purchase a new car at
the time but that Noah could share one
of the two family cars with his brother
when no one else in the family was using
it Noah accepted this and said thank you
however inside he was mad he saw his
friends new cars that they didn't have
to do anything for or share with anyone
he wanted to be like his friends and
have his friends families to get that
brand-new car and not have to worry
about anything he wondered what it must
be like to be that happy when Noah
turned 18 his mom got a promotion at her
company with their newfound extra income
Noah's parents decided to get him a
brand new car as a high school
graduation gift Noah could now drive
anywhere he wanted at anytime without
having to worry about sharing it the
life he wanted with his own car he now
had several years later Noah would
graduate from college with a degree in
business he didn't really know what he
wanted to do but he knew he wanted to
make a lot of money and that it could
lead to that after graduating he got a
job as an intern for a big corporation
throughout his internship Noah didn't
really enjoy his role and felt
unfulfilled and unhappy the work was
boring and never felt like it had
anything to do with him along the way
he made friends with some co-workers
though one of the employees that he
became acquainted with was the VP of
Sales and Marketing this individual had
a huge responsibility and influence in
the company he was clearly making a lot
of money and he would often treat
coworkers to nice dinners and events he
had nice things a big house a cool car
and beautiful women would gravitate to
him Noah wanted to be this man and have
that much authority money and all the
beautiful women he wondered what it must
be like to be that happy no I decided
that he needed to work harder and
dedicate himself to the company that he
needed to find his way into an important
role like that man he admired many more
years would go by and Noah was still at
the same company he worked hard
throughout those years really hard
he was hyper focused and stopped hanging
out with a lot of friends didn't see his
family as much and didn't really engage
in anything outside of work at this
point he had moved up numerous ranks in
the company and was making a lot more
money not far from the VP of Sales that
he envied as an intern Noah had now
bought himself his own home in a really
nice new car he had a decent amount of
disposable income and could buy most of
the things he wanted to and could go out
to nice restaurants and wear nice
clothes but Noah was still not very
happy or fulfilled by his work he was
working hard but things were still
boring and never felt like they had
anything to do with him every day felt
like the same and Noah found himself
always wishing for the day to be over
one day a friend from college that Noah
would still sometimes go out with on the
weekends told Noah how he recently
started working at a new company his
friend told him about how great this
company was how much opportunity there
was to grow to the top and do exciting
and important things how much money was
being invested into the company how much
higher the starting salary was how much
flexibility there was for employees how
nice everyone was including the owners
Noah wondered what it must be like to
work for such a great company he
wondered what it must be like to be that
happy
shortly after this conversation with his
friend Noah quit his job and got his
friend to refer him for a position at
this new company Noah got the job a
couple more years go by and Noah has
climbed his way up through a few ranks
at the company when all of a sudden it
gets bought out and Noah is laid off
Noah sees the company owners make
millions and millions of dollars while
he and most of the other employees lose
everything they work for with nowhere to
go and no remorse from anyone Noah
wondered what it must be like to be an
owner of a company like that to cash out
on a multi-million dollar deal and never
have to worry about working again he
wondered what it must be like to be able
to do whatever you want whenever you
want he wondered what it must be like to
be that happy
Noah realized he had been going at
everything all wrong he was tired of
working for other people only to get
screwed over at the end of the day he
realized that if he wanted to be happy
he needed to take control of his own
fortune so Noah collected a few
colleagues and friends who he had made
over the years to start a company with
he didn't know exactly what he wanted
the company to be but he knew he wanted
to make a lot of money and sell it at
some point with his newly established
business partners he brands
industry and what product or service
would be the most potentially lucrative
to start a business around seven more
years go by and Noah and his partners
have built a successful business with
promising growth throughout these years
noah has had even less time to himself
the demands of being a company owner and
building a business from the ground up
took everything noah had he had no time
outside of work he would wake up early
go to work get home late go to bed and
do it all again the next day he lived
and breathed the business he cut out
everyone in his life that wouldn't be of
use to his business he traveled all the
time and rarely saw his family
girlfriends would never last hobbies and
activities were completely off the table
but because of noah and his partners
hard work and their willingness to do
whatever it took to make their company
successful a major corporation became
interested in buying the business and
its intellectual property for a large
amount of money the deal was closed and
noah cashed out at fifteen million
dollars suddenly all of the things noah
wanted when he was a child
he can buy millions of any car he wanted
when he was a teenager he can buy
without feeling a dent any sense of
status power or luxury he wanted when he
was a young adult he has the big house
the women the fancy parties the nice
things the status he has it all a year
goes by it is Christmas
Noah's with his family this is one of
the few times a year he sees his brother
Alex Alex asks Noah how things are going
Noah tells Alex about how bored he is
not working anymore how he doesn't
really know what to do at this time and
feels kind of lost
he tells Alex how his remaining friends
only seem to care about business and
money how they don't appear to care
about him as a person rather just a
networking or business focal point he
shares how his last couple girlfriends
were shallow and never really seemed to
care about him or anything beyond money
he says how hard it is for him to meet
new good people and feel excited about
life alex empathizes with noah and
consoles him noah asks Alex how he has
been and what he's been up to alex says
things are pretty great and he's been
painting and camping a lot and playing
little guitar as well noah asks how he's
doing for money and if he needs any help
alex's thank you but that he's doing
fine he says that he has enough money
for him and his family to be comfortable
he says that he's been selling a lot of
his paintings photos and design
and has been doing pretty well with that
he says it's a constant grind but he
loves making every piece and seeing the
face of the people and clients that fall
in love with them that if he had to do
this for the rest of his life he would
still be thrilled every day Alex's wife
comes into the room holding the newborn
baby following her as a five year old
girl
Alex's other daughter Alex goes on to
share how great his wife is doing and
how great his kids are doing he says
they were planning a trip to Spain for
an art exhibition Noah sees the life in
his brothers eyes he sees the passion in
the sense of self he wonders what it
must be like to be that happy he wonders
why he never slowed down why he never
enjoyed himself and stopped comparing
himself to everyone around him why he
never appreciated what he had or what he
liked to do why he gave half his life to
becoming wealthy owning a bunch of stuff
and impressing strangers only to end up
alone unfulfilled and unhappy he asks
Alex how did you do it how did you find
so much happiness Alex responds Noah I
just didn't look so hard
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder